[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 22 octobre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 78 c'est
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale en 26
minutes tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
après une expérimentation en 2018 saint
quentin en yvelines a mis en place le
télétravail pour ces agents cette année
aujourd'hui 87 d'entre eux bénéficient
d'une journée de travail à domicile une
pratique peu répandu dans les
collectivités territoriales et des
jeunes des mureaux à la découverte du
savoir faire du château de versailles
dans le cadre d'une convention ils
viennent sur place régulièrement pour
connaître les différents métiers exercés
en ce mois d'octobre c'était au tour de
la profession de jardinier et puis les
meilleurs danseurs de hip hop des
environs à des rendez vous attrape les
sélections régionales des bboy france se
déroulait ce week-end focus sur les
bigors les qualifications défis et en
plateau également tout à l'heure le
responsable de l'uni a lu vs qu
l'organisation étudiante prépare
actuellement les prochaines élections à
l'université et on prendra des nouvelles
de louis burton le rambolitains qui
prendra pas dans qui prendra qui sera
engagé dans la transat jacques vabre qui
part du havre ce dimanche
[Musique]
une activité professionnelle exercée à
distance la plupart du temps à domicile
le principe du télétravail gain de temps
et de productivité
saint quentin en yvelines a adopté ce
procédé depuis peu après une phase de
test aujourd'hui 87 agents de
l'agglomération en profitent le
télétravail une pratique peu répandu
dans la fonction publique territoriale
reportage depuis le printemps dernier
mais wayne ne vient plus que quatre
jours par semaine à son bureau situé à
trappes son employeur l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines lui permet
d'effectuer une journée en télétravail
quand elle reste à son domicile pour
remplir ses missions ce sont 100 km de
trajet en voiture économiser beaucoup de
fatigue en moi du stress en moins lié
aux bouchons à la circulation
et puis du coup une amplitude de travail
élargie puisque voilà 2h à 2h30
transport en moins c'est sûr que c'est
autant de temps
de plus qu'assez sur le travail
aujourd'hui 87 agents de la collectivité
sont en télétravail il gagne en tout
près de 160 heures de trajet une mise en
place effective après une
expérimentation menée en 2018 en lien
avec les partenaires sociaux
ça permet aux agents de pouvoir
organiser leur vie un peu différemment
et tout le monde s'y retrouve on s'y
retrouve aussi sur le plan
environnemental
parce qu'elle a du coup on produit moins
de gaz toxiques
voilà où une voiture moins deux mois
d'utilisation de voitures et donc par
conséquent je pense que ça peut être
bénéfique bien sûr en tout cas bien
évidemment pour les agents à partir du
moment où le service public n'est pas
interrompue il ya aucune raison qu'une
chose ne se fasse pas saint quentin en
yvelines souhaite montrer l'exemple aux
autres collectivités en 2018 seulement à
0,1 pour cent des effectifs de la
fonction publique territoriale était en
télétravail est la campagne bat son
plein pour les municipales 2020 à
guyancourt le candidat rodolphe baril
est allé rencontrer les habitants à la
sortie des commerces échanges et
distribution de tracts pour présenter
son programme et sa liste qui se veut
sans étiquette marie la niaque et chino
et mathilde et demi il se balade un vélo
pour séduire les guyancourt toi avec sa
liste ensemble agissons pour guyancourt
rodolphe barry s'élance
dans sa campagne avec une liste sans
étiquette qui se veut ouverte à tous
l'objectif c'est d'aller à la rencontre
des guilands courtois donc il ya
plusieurs modes on a décidé nous d'y
aller à vélo parce que à la villa n'est
pas si grande que ça et c'est plus
simple pour pour poser place et puis
comment plus d'un point de vue
écologique on veut réduire l'empreinte
carbone de la commune on va pas non plus
nous déplacer en voiture donc comme la
ville n'est pas très grande
on se déplace en vélo de quartier en
quartier donc on a fait ça la semaine
dernière et puis ça super bien marché
distribution de tracts à la sortie des
commerces une technique qui ne marche
pas tout le temps mais qui séduit
certains habitants entraînant des
échanges constructifs
jean charles perrin donc forcément c'est
plus facile de faire d'avoir des gens
sur le terrain enfin de les rencontrer
fait de ne pas être interpellé d'avoir
un peu de temps d'avoir cinq minutes en
méchant aura d'ailleurs élu de la
majorité depuis plus de 18 ans à
guyancourt a rejoint la compagne de
rodolphe baril ne trouvant plus sa place
auprès de l'équipe municipale
elle se tourne désormais vers les
municipales 2020 avec une liste sans
étiquette
j'étais parti pour ne plus reprendre
vous pour faire la politique
j'étais sur le site de chaque candidat
j'ai fait des réunions publiques de
chaque candidat et donc j'ai rencontré
nous sort le baril à la fête de la
musique tout simplement je me suis
présentée à lui la liste sans étiquette
ensemble agissons pour guyancourt de
rodolphe baril se présentera face à
françois morton le maire sortant grégory
pape de la république en marche et
décidons ensemble à evian course en tête
de liste pour l'instant élections
municipales au programme les 15 et 22
mars prochains
autre scrutin qui arrivent les élections
au sein des différents conseils de l'ue
vs qu l'université versailles saint
quentin c'est au programme comme les
municipales au printemps prochain les
organisations étudiantes se prépare pour
l'échéance bonsoir de rigaud riche
châtillon bonsoir vous êtes le
responsable de l'uni a lu vs qu unis
pour union nationale pardon des inter
universitaire je vais leur faire union
nationale interuniversitaire l uni qui
se définit comme un mouvement des
étudiants de droite
quelles sont vos valeurs exactement dont
cluny c'est le
mouvement l'organisation politique
étudiante de droite qui existe depuis
1968 et qui défend les valeurs du mérite
du travail de la liberté d'étudier
contre les blocages notamment et de la
responsabilité
on a aussi les diplômes l'enseignement
supérieur comment exactement ça fait
partie de nos propositions de nos
valeurs l'une de nos propositions phares
c'est notamment la création d'une bourse
au mérite qui viendrait récompenser les
étudiants qui ont fourni un effort qui
ont travaillé durant leur semaine ce
trailer années et qui ont obtenu de bons
résultats
voilà c'est nos valeurs c'est notre
ambition pour l'université dans le fond
je pense que c'est un programme
pragmatique et cohérent alors comment
défendre justement les diplômes
d'enseignement supérieur vous l'avez dit
vous êtes anti blocage
comment on peut défendre les droits des
étudiants sans monter au créneau par des
blocages par exemple est-ce qu'on peut
on peut les défendre d'autres si simple
d'abord en se présentant par le scrutin
par la démocratie quand on a des
propositions et qu'on trouve des
personnes sur à mettre sur la piste
ensuite il ya le suffrage et ce sont les
étudiants qui décide dans les conseils
d'administration ensuite on peut prendre
des décisions peut faire des
propositions à la présidence de
l'administration et après c'est à l'avis
du conseil de trancher alors votre
présence à lui est ce que vous êtes à la
tête de l'ue ni depuis plus d'un an
c'est ça ça fait un peu moins d'un an
maintenant que je suis à la tête de
l'umih a lu vs qu organisation est ce
qu'elle est bien établie à lui est ce qu
est ce que ça paraissait assez mal
établies
désormais depuis le début d'année depuis
la fin de l'année dernière on a tenté
donc on fait en restructurant l'unît à
l'échelle de toute l'université
désormais il ya des référents dans
chaque faculté qui sont chargés de
trouver de nouveaux adhérents de trouver
de nouveaux militants et une fille née
de créer des listes pour les élections
et les de faire gagner nos idées mais
lens est rentré vous avez de nouveaux
adhérents
bien sûr une vingtaine de nouveaux
adhérents c'est ça s'annonce assez bien
pour cette année alors vous parliez pour
peser injustement dans les décisions de
l'ue vs q2 de représentation au sein du
conseil d'administration aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas lui ni n'est pas
présent au conseil des sages sont peu
présents dans les conseils
d'administration de l'univers santé dans
les concessions trop il y a
il semble enfin c'est un élu dans le
haut centraux et après on a un est due
dans l'académie donc au crous qui
prennent des décisions notamment sur les
tarifs d des plats sur les tarifs des
logements etc
mais ça c'est une représentation au
niveau de l'académie de versailles c'est
au niveau des académies donc là au
niveau de l'académie de versailles
les prochaines échéances pour vous est
entièrement tourné vers ces élections
vers l'élévation des centraux on est
tourné donc pour mars et avril prochain
et les crous seront renouvelés mais en
fin d'année 2020 donc pour cette année
universitaire c'est avant tout les
centraux qui seront importants
l'objectif j'imagine c'est de faire
élire des représentants de l'ue ni au
sein de ces conseils exactement
l'objectif c'est de gagner le plus de
voix de de faire connaître notre projet
de le créer avec les étudiants parce que
c'est avant tout pour défendre leurs
attentes leurs besoins donc
on sera présent sur le terrain pour pour
défendre leurs intérêts il commence à se
préparer y aura un référent pour chaque
vague était différent pour chaque
faculté il y a des référents pour chaque
faculté
donc ils sont chargés de créer des
listes de d'établir des programmes bien
précis et qui répond directement aux
j'ai rapport revendications mais aux
besoins directs des étudiants et donc ça
doit être adaptée au besoin par faculté
par sa faculté à ses spécificités et et
à ses spécificités à ses besoins
il y en a par exemple qui sont en
économie qui aime développer des projets
autour de l'entrepreneuriat est bon on
doit soutenir ces projets là on doit les
accompagner les aider par des mesures
fiscales donc à ce niveau là et puis
d'autres qui qui font autre chose et
qu'ils ont besoin aussi de notre aide
vous disiez être à l'écouté de leurs
besoins ça veut dire le programme global
on le connaît mais il y aura des
ajustements c'est ça justement il y aura
d une écoute des étudiants et on pourra
adapter le programme en fonction de ce
qu'ils désirent tout simplement que ça
ça va se décider dans les prochaines
semaines des élections il ya des
rencontres peut-être organiser ça va se
décider dans les prochaines semaines là
déjà l'objectif c'est de toujours
recruter davantage donc tous les
vendredis on essaye d'être sur le
terrain dans une faculté différentes
tous ensemble et un vendredi par mois on
essaye le soir de faire un apéro pour
pour débattre pour pour évoquer
plusieurs sujets et crée ensuite d'aider
des listes avec des programmes et des
des propositions que j'allais vous
demandez les prochaines actions c'est ça
c'est d'organiser ces rencontres c'est
des prochaines actions pour lui ni à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
merci à grégory châtillon je rappelle
que vous êtes le responsable de l'union
inter universitaire à l'université
versailles saint quentin
merci d'être patient sato cette
association à présent entre le château
de versailles et la commune des mureaux
au coeur de versailles c'est un
programme de trois ans qui se terminera
en 2021 l'objectif du projet proposer à
des jeunes sortis du système scolaire ou
en recherche d'orientation plusieurs
métiers d'art et de savoir faire du
château en ce mois d'octobre c'était le
métier de jardinier qui avait été
choisie on revient sur cette découverte
avec mathilde 2000 ce sont 120 jeunes
qui ont découvert les jardins du grand
trianon entourée d'arbres de fleurs et
d'arbustes
ils visitent le domaine accompagnés de
leur guide yvan jardiner au château de
versailles
on a parlé du
la différence entre un jardin anglais un
jardin français en fait c'est une des
spécificités du jardin que j'entretiens
c'est le jardin anglais de marie
antoinette qui c'est le seul parti à
l'anglais the two versailles c'est à
dire que c'est des allées sinueuses les
arbres sont laissés encore libres c'est
un endroit où on doit reproduire la
nature on veut reproduire les plus
belles choses de la nature
contrairement aux jardins français où
tout est rectiligne toutes les droites
symétrique
kabré même si le métier de jardinier ne
l'a pas séduite
mina collégienne à admirer les fleurs et
les statuts et a même pu goûter des
fruits cultivés dans le jardin on a
appris des nouvelles choses qu'on ne
savait pas par exemple on a mangé un
fruit tout à l'heure un fruit de la
forêt en fait on a cru qu'il est quand
comme on dit que c'est un poison en fait
c'est pas du tout un poison c'est un
truc qu'on - gilles a un goût de comme
la brique on va dire à l'intérieur
durant les trois ans du programme
les jeunes pourront découvrir des
métiers parfois originaux comme un
sellier maroquinier un paquet heures un
marbrier ou encore un top 10 et on a
choisi de faire quelque chose qui se
rapproche plus d'une volonté de
permettre aux jeunes de découvrir
versailles sous un autre jour celui de
ses métiers de ses pratiques
professionnelles très diverse très
variées qu'on n'imagine pas toujours le
grand public d'une manière générale et
donc encore plus quand on est jeune et
qu'on sait pas trop qu'est ce qu'on a
envie de faire de son avenir
un projet qui permet à certains jeunes
de trouver leur orientation dans un
métier qu'ils ne connaissent pas au
coeur de versailles se terminera en 2021
de quoi créer encore quelques vocations
le sport il a été dévoilé hier le comité
d'organisation des jeux olympiques 2024
de paris a présenté le logo de
l'événement le voit s'il se destine à
actuellement à l'écran trois symboles
ont été choisis pour réaliser le visuel
la médaille d'or pour le sport la flamme
pour le mouvement olympique et
paralympique et marianne image de la
france rappelons que si l'événement est
siglé jo de paris
il se déroulera aussi en région
francilienne 1 sur plusieurs sites
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste au
vélodrome national de bmx à lille de
loisirs tout proche le golf récente
discipline olympique se tiendra au golf
national qui a accueilli la ryder cup
enfin les épreuves de vtt sont prévus
sur la colline d'elancourt c'est l'une
des trois compétitions majeures de voile
la transat jacques vabre débute dimanche
départ du havre direction le brésil et
un rambolitains louis burton va
participer à cette course au large il se
rend en duo avec l'un de ses amis de
toujours davy beaudart est nickel elle
me doit rencontrer louis burton patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les moyens
techniques à mes côtés laurent bolitar
louis burton que nous avons réussi à
avoir juste avant son départ
on est à paris et il est prêt il est
prêt à louis burton
oui bonjour à tous ainsi toujours un
plaisir de venir en ile de france on se
voit régulièrement avant les départs de
course on est à 15 jours du départ de la
jacques vabre et
on est prêt avec vaud valais on est prêt
avec des vies bon il reste encore
quelques petites choses à caler
notamment les rendez vous avec les
sponsors les médias etc
mais bon c'est c'est la partie sympa du
boulot donc le départ c'est le 27
octobre
qu'est ce qui reste à faire c'était
intelligent alors on va partir de saint
malo pour monter au havre au départ de
la transat jacques vabre
17 donc la semaine prochaine entre temps
on doit encore faire nos sacs de
vêtements on doit faire nos sacs de
nourriture vérifier que on a
suffisamment niggaz vérifier tous les
derniers petits aspects logistiques
qu'on repousse un peu au dernier moment
parce qu'on priorise d'abord sur la
préparation du bateau donc là on est
vraiment sur les tous derniers
préparatifs
ces bateaux il est comment alors c'est
un bateau qui a gagné le dernier vendée
globe
c'était l'ancien banque populaire c'est
un bateau qu'on a pu améliorer encore
cette année pendant le chantier d'hiver
on à m'aider me des systèmes qui
permettent de régler les files et donc
d'améliorer encore les performances
c'est un bateau qui devrait nous
permettre de jouer en tête cette année
pendant la transat jacques vabre tout
cas on espère jean pas que j'en parle
trop parce que faut pas porter malheur
mais c'est c'est vraiment une belle
machine
l'année dernière vous aviez abandonné
assez tôt est ce que cette année vous
êtes plus confiant alors c'est vrai que
sur la route du rhum je progresse était
sur la route du rhum 2018 c'est c'est
toujours un grand coup dur quand
on ne peut pas aller au bout d'une
course ça avait duré 12 heures l'année
dernière cette année on a renforcé tout
ce qui pouvait à nouveau cassé tout ce
qui était calculé un peu trop léger
aujourd'hui on a un bateau qui est
fiable normalement après ça reste un
sport mécanique donc
c'est un peu comme en formule 1 ça va
être à nous de gérer pour pas appuyer
trop sur le bateau quand la les
conditions de mer sont trop difficiles
il faut terminer et
idéalement terminé en étant le plus
devant possible cette transat ça
représente quoi pour vous la transat
jacques vabre donc ça va être ma
cinquième participation d'affilée
c'est une
une course mythique elle existe depuis
longtemps et c'est une course
que moi j'adore personnellement parce
qu'on l'a fait en double on est très
souvent solitaire sur nos bateaux et et
de faire une course à deux c'est sympa
en général et ça permet de d'exploiter à
120% les bateaux puisque pendant il y en
a un qui veille et qui règle le bateau
l'autre d'or se repose donc voilà c'est
une course très dure mais
que j'affectionne particulièrement parce
qu'on est deux à bord vous serez avec
comme coéquipier dans le bateau vous
serez avec davy beaudart qui glisse et
davy beaudart on connaît pas forcément
le grand public ne connaît pas forcément
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un en qui vous
avez confiance alors davy beaudart oui
c'est un ami de longue date puisque on
s'est connu sur le circuit irc donc les
régates en habitable quand on avait 18
ans on a le même âge on est
marié tous les deux on a on a deux
enfants on a vraiment un parcours de vie
communs donc toute la préparation se
comprend
vous voulez partager un événement de ce
type ensemble oui oui c'est vrai que en
fait des villes et il est très bon sur
lomé depuis à peu près 15 ans il fait ce
qu'on appelle la mini transat qui vient
de partir là et ça tombe toujours
pendants les transats jacques vabre et
donc on n'avait jamais pu partir et
cette année il faisait pas la
mini-transat donc j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion pour pour lui proposer cette
course et c'est un binôme qui qui j'ai
confiance je sais qu'il prendra soin de
moi je sais qu'il a l'objectif d'aller
le plus vite possible
et puis dans la vie professionnelle il a
il a un chantier naval est donc
techniquement il est il est vraiment au
point sur l'eau vous allez être
complémentaires alors on est assez
complémentaire dans la préparation sur
l'eau on est on est complémentaires en
tout cas on peut pas vraiment dire qu'on
soit complémentaire on fait tout
ensemble et à 2 on a tous les deux des
parcours de
skipper solitaire donc on va plutôt
confronter nos points de vue et puis nos
prises de décisions et et c'est ce qui
rend d'ailleurs cette navigation avec
lui si intéressante la préparation tout
s'est passé comment justement alors on a
dû déjà
réparer bureau vallée suite à la route
du rhum ça a été ça a été un gros
challenge parce qu'il y avait eu je sais
pas s'il vous rappeler mais il y avait
une voie d'eau très importante
j'avais embarqué plusieurs tonnes d'eau
à l'intérieur du bateau donc il ya eu
sept mois de chantier jusqu'au mois de
juin à peu près de préparation et
ensuite ça a été des navigations de la
mise au point des navigations de la mise
au point ça c'est sur la partie partie
nautique à une course importante qui est
le fastnet qu'on a couru en août où on a
terminé quatrième et ensuite beaucoup de
préparation sur l'eau qui n'est à terre
pardon sur le kiné ostéo coach sportive
enfin voilà histoire d'être à peu près
en ligne en forme pour un bateau de
depuis son sol est ce que cette transat
jacques vabre est une préparation pour
le vendée globe ou est ce que c'est un
objectif en soi
terminer dans le top 5 alors au top 3
c'est un objectif en soi puisque c'est à
mes yeux
la troisième course la plus importante
du plateau après le vendée globe et la
route du rhum donc il ya vraiment de
l'enjeu on est attendus sur cette course
on va être une trentaine de bateaux de
la catégorie imoca et puis c'est une
course qui en même temps en effet va
nous servir à se jauger contre les
autres pour le vendée globe puisque
quasiment tous les nouveaux bateaux qui
vont courir l'année prochaine le tour du
monde sont sortis donc on va pouvoir
ben voilà voir qui qui va plus vite
potentiellement qui va moins vite et et
se mettre à jour par rapport aux
concurrents pour l'année prochaine mais
vous y serez sûrement des glaces oui on
y sera avec leurs valets pour la
troisième année consécutive troisième
édition consécutive les victoires sont
envisageables sur cette transat jacques
vabre sans ça risque d'être encore un
petit peu juste il faut pas faut pas
faire de pronostics comme ça mais parce
que ça porte malheur
on est un peu superstitieux dans la
voile mais oui on a on a un bateau qui
peut permettre de jouer devant et on
s'est beaucoup entraîné cette année donc
on a ça quelque part dans un coin de
notre tête
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter à
cette transat vous terminez déjà
d'arriver au brésil c'est important même
pour se remettre de la route du rhum
c'est un ça vraiment beaucoup
d'importance d'aller au bout et puis ben
dette entre cinquième et premier on sera
content merci beaucoup
burton la transat jacques vabre c'est le
27 octobre et par deux piles au havre
et le 27 octobre donc c'est ce dimanche
départ de la transat jacques vabre
depuis le port du havre
les meilleurs danseurs et danseuses de
hip hop de la région étaient à la merise
attrape ce week-end au programme les
sélections régionales du championnat à
bboy france l'une des compétitions phare
de la discipline cette année marylène
iapichino et nicolas landry ont suivi
les qualifications des beagles les
qualifications fille pour la deuxième
année consécutive les qualifications
régionales pour le championnat de danse
urbaine bboy france se déroulait à la
merise attrape le département des
yvelines est un précurseur dans la
pratique du breakdance
un espèce d'engouement et une force qui
vient de désigner des baies 3 1 des bacs
blancs beurs voilà il ya plein de
petites associations qui sont mis à côté
a travaillé également avec différents
styles avec différents événements et
puis c'est normal qu'au niveau de
territoire il ya un lieu de diffusion
sont représentés et donc à la maurice en
tout cas leur lot réouverte deux
journées de compétition pour remporter
sa place en finale la semaine suivante
dans le nord ce dimanche place aux
juniors et aux piigs
j'essaye de faire une heure
d'entraînement tous les jours et bah je
révise je fais que les visées et lors du
baptême bassam enfilé garçons sous tous
sont toujours au devant de la scène ça
faut pas se mentir parce que voilà là on
va dire que ils ont une place qui était
là depuis depuis très longtemps mais
les filles on arrive en tout cas on
arrive et beaucoup d'organisateurs font
en sorte de changer les choses sur 46
participants elles étaient dix à
concourir en catégorie piqueur la
discipline ces féministes peuple ça se
passe très bien
il faut savoir que le breakdance rentrer
jeux olympiques normalement 2024 à paris
justement et il y aura la catégorie
filles aussi qui sera représentée donc
ça tout va bien aucun evelyne mois ne
s'est qualifiée chez les filles cécile j
eunes seine et marnaise qui représentera
l'île de france
on referme ce journal par la découverte
d'une formation musicale unique en son
genre le quatuor à cordes de l'armée de
terre il est musicien qui la composent
sont tous des militaires ils sont basés
dans les yvelines à satory et donne en
ce moment une série de concerts aurélie
rose
ils sont violonistes violoncellistes
altiste deux femmes deux hommes qui
forment le quatuor à cordes de l'armée
de terre basé à satory cette formation
est unique en son genre car elle est la
seule au sein de l'armée et musiciens
sont des militaires ils ont tous été
recrutés par concours a moi la musique
c'est depuis tout petit j'ai des parents
qui sont logicien voilà j'ai fait des
études d'écriture aussi j'ai étudié en
allemagne je fais des arrangements pour
le quatuor aussi en fait j y ai
complètement qu'il y avait les musiciens
l'armée de terre je savais que la garde
la garde républicaine existait et donc
en fait je savais pas qu'on pouvait à la
fois tenir une arme et un violon dans
les mains
[Musique]
ce quatuor à cordes fait partie du
commandement des musiques de l'armée de
terre habituellement il se produit pour
les plus hautes autorités civiles et
militaires mais pour mieux les faire
connaître certaines représentations sont
ouvertes au public une première
le but de cette série de concerts
c'était les faire découvrir
déjà d'une à la population versaillaise
parce que je pense que les versailles et
ne savent pas qu'il y ait un quatuor
dans leur ville de leur montrer aussi
que nos musiciens militaires peuvent
jouer bien évidemment du répertoire
classique le quatuor américain de dvorak
mais d'ubs et off du hyde en fait tu lis
peuvent ils peuvent tous jouer
après la musique américaine les
prochains moments musicaux du quatuor à
cordes seront consacrés aux musiques
d'halloween ou encore de noël quarante
minutes de concert qui demande une
préparation quotidienne
nous devons être présents à la caserne
de 8h à 17h ton commence à répéter tous
ensemble vers 10h à peu près voilà et
ensuite l'après midi on alterne entre
travail personnel et répétitions à 4 en
fonction du programme qu'on a monté des
concerts qu'on a à faire
l'auditorium peut accueillir jusqu'à 80
personnes pour découvrir le quatuor à
cordes de l'armée terre il suffit de
s'inscrire prochain rendez vous les 7 et
27 novembre
[Applaudissements]
ce reportage et bien d'autres encore à
retrouver dans l'émission et 7,8 culture
tour d'horizon des prochains spectacles
expositions et concerts en compagnie
d'aurélie rond et c'est dans un instant
sur atv 78 voilà à la fin de ce journal
merci d'avoir suivi et j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]